man thinks that Mikhail I guess yeah
nikhil told me my main objective is to
aim the level so that experts will be
bored so I guess you know I really want
to make sure nikhil is bored so if you
see any kid either
engaged or interested let me know and
I'll either talk about something else or
slow down
okay so we are talking about stochastic
methods in our Pathmark wise analysis in
the Quran hypercube what I'll do is
mainly just kind of introduce a few
tools and basic things I'll prove a few
theorems using stochastic methods I
won't prove a lot of new theorems maybe
we'll have time to to prove just one new
theorem uh most of the things I'll prove
actually have different proofs by proofs
by more classical techniques but the aim
here is you know just to learn the
technique rather than
to you know learn how to prove new
theorems
uh just to make sure you
um
can you say something I just want to
know that I can hear you if someone is
not following so I think uh we have to
use the mic to for you
so I don't know try to stop me if
someone has a question okay I wanna take
it slow and we want to make sure
everyone is following me
okay so let's start with a
with the proof of that one color
inequality which I guess you all know
this proof is going to be a bit of an
Overkill in terms of Tours but I think
but it's going to lead us to being able
to prove more sophisticated things
so the first thing I want to remind you
is what a
multi-linear extension
of a Boolean function is
yes are you writing Ronan because we
don't see it
today I am riding okay wow yeah
very slow
ly also yeah can you remind us what the
pankara inequality is yeah sure let's
remind you you have one correct
well it is
yeah it's I don't know why is it so slow
though
um
this is going to be okay
hopefully it's gonna improve
uh
if I have a Boolean function I can
Define the I influence of s so for f
bullets function let's say from now less
than a 10 cow I'll try to reconnect
with my iPad right what are you say in a
kill it's it's like really annoying and
it usually works fine
sure yeah this is slow so we could try
again yeah if there's a different device
yeah story about that I have no idea why
this is happening I did this so many
times and it always works
it's fine
yeah
you know what they think maybe it's
improved okay let's let's do one last
attempt
like can you see me highlighting the
word is quality now yeah okay
okay
so if I have a Boolean function uh
or let's say two zero one
I can we denote the I influence of f by
simply the expectations
over the uniform measure that
of the
of Del I of f
where the ice discrete derivative of f
at X is equal to
you know uh
f x x where I set the I coordinates to
B1
minus f x
where is that the I coordinate to be
minus
so remember is a lag um is it also on
your end or
uh I let let me just reconnect because
it's going to be
right okay sorry about that guys
okay
there's the button optimized for video
okay now I see there is no lag but the
quality is very crappy right
can you see my screen like yeah but you
can barely read yeah yeah
I really don't get it like my Wi-Fi
connection is like really good
sorry let me reconnect to the Wi-Fi
so
much
foreign
[Music]
no
still the bloody oh yeah
better not perfect but still yeah not
perfect but I think we'll have to go
with this uh yeah I think it's legible
yeah yeah
um but is there a delay or can you I I
think there is no delay now this looks
better yeah
uh yeah really not perfect you know what
I mean but this is good if this is yeah
it's good okay yeah sorry I have no idea
why this is happening
okay so if I Define the influences like
this which is just you know the
probability the toggling to the I chord
in it is going to toggle the value of
the function app the pawn Korean
equality which is probably the most
basic
inequality uh
or the most basic concentration
inequality on the hypercube state
that
the variance of f
is bounded
by the sum over I of I I
and yeah what uh what I'm gonna do first
is give you a pretty convoluted proof of
this which
will be useful because we were going to
be able to extend it pretty easily to
uh
stronger inequalities
no I think less than I think this is let
me try one last thing sorry about that
let me actually try to
um go closer to the
Wi-Fi router maybe it's the connection
don't you really Square the derivative
it doesn't matter because it's Boolean
write the square of like plus minus ones
yeah
equal to the absolute value
sorry uh let me try to get closer to the
router maybe not
I don't know if it's better or not
flexible with this spring
okay
uh so what's the multi-linear extension
of the Korean function so
I guess this you all know
I can always write f of x as
the Fourier decomposition so the sum
overall subsets of the nth coordinates
of the coordinates of some
coefficients that depends on the subset
so this is sometimes called
the Fourier transformed
times
the characteristic function of this
subset
right
now we're we're actually not going to
care at all about the values of those
coefficients
the only thing we care about is that
there exists such a representation
which identifies with f on you know the
discrete type review
but we're going to use it outside of the
display type review so this is actually
defined for all
X in our n
and in particular
for all X in the convex style of the
display type of you
right
and
it has a very and like by definition
it's multilinear and since it's
multilinear it's also a harmonic
function
which is kind of going to be uh
what's going on
which is going to be useful for us later
on
next I want to define the following
thing I want to Define
a stochastic process takes zero what's a
harmonic function
ah that harmonic function is a function
whose uh laplacian is zero so
um
second derivatives yeah exactly so now
it's going to be continuous and not this
great derivative so for all X
if I look at you know the sum overall I
uh
Del
in fact it's much more than that like
each
each of the second derivatives is
actually zero right because
if I take the derivative twice in the
same direction I just get zero
but we're just going to use instance the
harmonicity
okay now let's define uh the following
stochastic process x 0 weeks one up to X
10. I want to Define it as follows
so these are all going to be points in
-1
0 or 1 to the n
and I want to take
K1 up to k n
to be a random permutation
of the numbers 1 to n
and that and
Epsilon 1 up to or
up to Epsilon n to be uh
Bernoulli
uh
plus minus ones I choose plus or minus
one with probability f i ID
and then I want to Define
x i minus x i minus one to be
Epsilon I
times the
standard basis vector
k i
I so just you know A1
up to e and it's a standard basis
so basically what I do is like the
process x i starts from the center
at any point in time it chooses one of
the coordinates uniformly chooses
uniformly at random one of the remaining
coordinates in which it didn't jump yet
and in this coordinate it jumps to plus
or minus one with probability one half
so maybe it starts here and then it's
going to jump like over here and then
it's going to jump over here so this
will be like x0 X1 X2
okay
so you know clearly
uh x n is going to be uniform in the
display type of queue
which means that you know
if I now Define m i to be f of x i
then the variance
of
m n
is just the variance of that
right
and recall that I want an upper bound on
the variance of it
by the sum of the influences
right
and I claim that
also
the sum of the influences of that
is by definition equal
to
or maybe let's write 1 over n the sum of
the influences of n is by definition
equal to the
expectation
of m i minus m i minus 1.
Square
why because well
if we go back to this specified
picture
you know so the Maybe
this coordinate jumps first and then the
second the third and maybe the last
coordinate the jumps is like this
coordinates
so you know m i will be F at this point
Sorry m i minus 1 will be F at this
point
m i will be asked that you know one of
those two points
and then the difference between
this and this is just going to be you
know
foreign
what's written in the brackets is
basically
like
sorry okay I guess there's a
Factor two that I missed in but
this is basically
the gradient the partial derivative
in the k i Direction f
at
X and
uh
squared
Maybe
which is you know equal to the
influence of the Ki coordinator
uh
this is true foreign
so there is a question uh
sir why is this true when I is not equal
to n when some of the coordinates might
be zero
Starry why is this true an i is not
equal to n when some of the coordinates
might be zero
ah sorry sorry yeah yeah I'm
sorry about that I'm
okay
this should be an n my bad
yeah yeah of course of course
this is and this is M this is M and this
is M sorry sure okay I'm glad someone is
following
yeah it's it's just the last one right
it's we basically reveal coordinates by
coordinates and the jump that we have in
this
process Mi with respect to the last
coordinate we reveal
that's just like equal to
you know the influence of the last
important and if we take expectation
it's just you know the expectation over
all the influence
right
now an easy fact
that's going to be useful for us is that
the process am I
is a Marvin Gaye
do we need to
Mikhail what do you say everyone knows
what a Martindale is or maybe quickly
remind yeah sure so that just means that
the expectation of m i
given all the past so the past year is
x0 up to x i minus 1.
is equal to
you know so
um so so I claim that in the end it's
going to be equal to
uh
m i minus one
and what's the reason for this
um you know this is just
so it's equal to
the expectation of m i
given X naught up to x i minus one and
also
k i
so suppose I already know in which
coordinate I'm going to jump
in the I stab
and then you know I can take expectation
over Ki
so this is just the same now what is
this this is so here the only Randomness
I have I already know in which
coordinates the process is gonna jump
the only Randomness is you know this
Epsilon I
so here it's just you know equal to
with probability one-half
I'm jumping you know to x i minus 1 plus
e
um
I
sorry k i
and with probability one half
minus E K I right
and the point is that f is linear over
you know this line that is spanned by
these two uh points right
so the average is just
the average so this is just
foreign
so
this is the Martingale and for
martingales we have a pretty nice
property saying the following thing so
for any Martingale so for for any
process
am I such that the expectation of
um I
uh given you know everything that
happened until
Maybe
yeah
everything that happened until you know
M I'm I minus one is equal to m i minus
one
so if you have this
then
the variants of
M at any time I maybe let me
am I 2 minus M maybe that's okay
don't want to burden you with notation
MJ minus m i
is equal to the expectation
of the sum
of all uh t
between
I and J
uh m t minus m
T minus one
squared
so I guess uh
many of you have seen this I mean
to to see why this is true you just open
the brackets
and you see that the only terms that are
not zero in expectation are basically
the squares of so you know I can just
write the variances like this telescopic
sum
should I do this okay let me do this
so you know this is just MJ minus
minus this one
plus then J minus one
J minus two
etc etc
the square of this if I you know just
open the brackets I get a bunch of terms
that you know I get the squares of like
these terms
which are exactly these terms but also I
get you know
for example this term times this term
in expectation is just zero because you
know the expectation of MJ given every
all of this
is just MJ minus one right
so
foreign
so you know this is a very simple fact
but it's going to be very useful for us
so given so
given this I know that the variance of
which is the variance of them and
is equal to you know the expected sum
I between one and n
of
am I am i x one squared
right
and
note that here already so if we look at
this thumb
the last stamant in this sum is
basically uh what we had
uh here
right
so I have a sum over a bunch of terms
where the LA the last one of them is
just you know the average influence of
that
okay
so all we
all we wanted we want to stay now is
that
you know the
that this thumb
so what we want to show is that
this sounds
is less or equal
than the same then basically
n times
right
expectation which will follow from the
fact that the expectation of m i minus m
i minus 1.
where is less or equal than the
expectation of m n minus m n minus 1.
squared for all I
so in a sense you know you you can think
about so so
those differences are increasing in
expectation you know what I have so I
have this process that starts here and
first you know I reveal the first
coordinate and then the second and the
third and every time I reveal a
coordinate I get some information about
where
what the final value of f will be right
first time here I have like f of 0 which
is just the expectation of f
over the entire discrete hypercube and
then I reveal the first bit so you know
maybe I'll have
a f here you know this is going to be F
of X1
I mean this point is X1
and then I have F of X1
so you know I revealed
a little bit of information about where
f is going to where the Martingale m is
going to end up and when I reveal the
second coordinate I reveal
another little bit of information
and the point of this inequality is that
the amount of information
that is revealed in every step is
increasing
like the last step is telling you more
than the first step
does that make sense
hopefully
okay so let's let's try to prove this
inequality
so by definition
m i minus m i minus
one
is equal
to the gradient of f
uh
at X
I minus one
or maybe
let me write it like that partial k i
f x i minus 1. of f x i minus 1 times
Epsilon I
right
by definition like
I was here and then I moved either here
or here so you know the difference is
determined by the
gradient of F at this point
times you know my offset
so now
but
another easy fact that
basically photos from the same reason as
the previous fact is that
for all I
Dell I of f
or maybe for all J
the process Del J of F at x i
is also a modern world
and the reason it's exactly the same
reason if I look at Del J of f that's
also a multi-linear function
so it's exactly the same approach
right
so now
all we have to write is the following
thing so the expectation of them I minus
m i minus one
where
this is equal to
um
the expectation of
maybe let's uh
do it so
first we need to choose in which
coordinate we move
and then we need to take the expectation
over uh basically where x i minus 1 is
of Del k i
f
x i minus 1.
uh
where
right
now let's uh give this
okay actually now let's let's do this so
this I claim that this is less or equal
than
same expectation over k i
and
now
I want to take
the expectation and now instead of Del k
i f at x i minus one I want to take F at
xn
squared
so let's uh okay we'll prove this
inequality in a second but let's just
agree that once we prove this inequality
then we're done if we now take the
actual expectation over k i then we just
get you know
which
yeah
so you know okay is just uniform
so what I get is just this thumb over I
or
maybe let me call it okay
of
the expectation of
Delhi okay
extend
squared one over n
which is equal to
the sum of influences
Okay so
the inequality we wanted to uh
prove here
will follow or actually it's exactly
this inequality
so all we have to to show is like this
is all we're missing
okay
but now there is actually not so much to
do because we already know
that
what's written here
that the this expression
is a Martingale
so
well it's a Martingale with respect too
so so maybe
in order to not confuse you let's uh
denote by n I and T
Del k i f
x t
and I know that this is the Martingale
with respect to T so I I think of it as
fast
and so and therefore Kai is also fixed
and T is changing so this is like the
process
a stochastic process parameterized by T
so this is a Martingale
with respect to T
which means which implies that uh
the expectation of an i t
squared is increasing by the answer
so maybe
to elaborate on that if I have any
process than one
one two and
then
where the expectation
and I given
N1 up to nine
is equal to n i minus one then and for
every
convex function
we have that the expectation of
by of MI
is so this is exactly the answer
given all these values
is
bigger equal
right
okay so as you can see it took me a long
time to prove the point Korean equality
and I think I uh maybe even like
confused you a little bit in the middle
but
does anyone have any questions
so far
okay
good
so
foreign
step back for a second and
I want to talk about different ways to
sample a single random bit
so
here for every coordinate you know at
some point we sample this coordinate it
was equal to zero and then you know we
tossed the coin of probabilities half
and half
and then you know we got plus and minus
one
there are other ways to sample a random
bit for example I can do I can have the
the following scheme so maybe
first I tossed
a
one-half one-half coin
if I get uh heads
I just
a
one quarter
or actually let's do
two thirds one third coin
if I get heads again
my
sampled bit is one and if I get tails
then
my sampled bit will be minus one
and maybe here if I get tails
then also I tossed
but now like one third two thirds coin
and
if I get heads
then my sampled bit will be plus one
sure
and if we get tails
it's going to be minus
so
do you agree that like it's still a 50
50 probability to get plus or minus one
right but instead of just doing you know
one sample of a bit in a stance I
sampled something which is like less
than a four bit
when I know when I tell you the result
of this coin it gives you some
information
on what the final result is likely to be
right if I get heads it's going to be
more likely to be heads than tails
but
you know I still need to toss another
coin
in order to know like
what the final bit is going to be
and
you know we can come up with infinitely
many schemes like that like infinitely
many algorithms that are going to sample
eventually random bit and I claim that
every such scheme so this is an example
of a scheme but every such scam
has a one-to-one correspondence
to some Martingale
XT
ouch that
x0 is equal to zero and X1
is
either -1 or plus one
so
this particular example is the following
Martingale
so so now just for convenience you know
that the values of time here will not be
integers they'll be you know fractions
of
the
the interval 0 1. so this this
particular example corresponds to the
following thing you know X zero
is is here X1 is going to be with
probability one-half it's minus one half
so this is minus one this is plus one
so X
at time one half is going to be
you know minus one half with probability
one half and plus one half
with probability one half
right
so x one half is either here or here
and then you know X1 is is going to be
sampled in the unique way
so that this is the marginal so you know
if I was here
since this interval is three times
longer than this interval
I have
you know uh
relative probabilities of you know
one-third and two-thirds to jump in
every direction
questions about this
so you know if if this is kind of a way
to sample a reaction of the bit I can
also you know I can also find
if p
is the unique solution
to
one plus p over to log one plus two
should it be like 1 4 and 3 4 instead of
one third and two third or
uh
or wow yeah sorry I slept very badly
tonight but yes it should be bored
yeah that that was completely dumb sorry
about that but you know
I'm very glad you are following
uh yeah so if p is the unique solution
to
this equation
so this is you know the point where
the entropy I have left is exactly one
half
of the entire entropy that we have in
sampling one bit
then you know ideologically I can you
know I can just set x one half is equal
to
okay I guess p is the bet
it's bad notation that's quality Q
one half x one half is Q with
probability you know one half and minus
Q with probability one half
and then I get that you know h of X1 the
entropy I'm not going to Define it
because it's not going to be important
later it's just for the sake of example
is you know
is equal to one half the entropy
of X1 meaning that you know I just
instead of sampling an entire bit in
terms of entropy example half a bit
and then I sample the other half that's
left
and we can also do it in infinitesimal
right so
another way to sample
which will be
which is the main way we're going to
focus on later on so actually two more
ways
which are continuous
so the first one if we take a break
I'm just going to write two more lines
and then we can take
and take okay so
the first one I can
we're going to show that there exists a
process
XT
let's touch that
first of all XD is a Martingale
stack and second of all
the absolute value of x t is always
equal to T
so in particular x 0 is 0 and X1 is one
but you know I always know the absolute
value
that kind of means that you know x t has
to jump between the Curve
you know plus T and minus t
and that process if you think about it
for a bit it's like kind of a continuous
way if I go from you know T to t plus DT
I only give you uh an infinite decimal
information about where X1 is going to
end
and the second process
is going to be
x t is just going to be BT
stop
at plus minus one so B at the minimum of
T and the stopping time
which is the smallest s
such that BS
is plus minus one
where B is a Brownian motion which I
will
Define
later on so this is kind of just food
for thought okay but yeah now in the
break maybe I'll let you stare at those
two things and
you know try to think about them
okay
containing in a few minutes I guess ah
continuing a half an hour I guess
yeah many cool questions
any questions
[Music]
okay so let's meet in at 11.